When Marvel's biggest film of 2018, the exhilarating
and surprisingly sad superhero ensemble Avengers:
Infinity War, hit Netflix on December 25th,
fans were delighted.
A Christmas present from the Home of Heroes
and the number-one streaming platform in the
world?
A chance to watch the super-sized flick in
their pajamas, sunk into the corner of their
couch and hiding behind a bowl of popcorn
where no one could judge them for crying when
Spider-Man said a tearful goodbye to Iron
Man in the last few minutes of the film?
Who wouldn't be excited by that?
Unfortunately, elation turned to outrage for
a vocal contingent of Marvel fans when Netflix
users discovered the Infinity War plot summary.
At the time the film hit the streaming site,
its description read, "Superheroes amass to
stop intergalactic sociopath Thanos from acquiring
a full set of Infinity Stones and wiping out
half of all life in the universe."
As it turns out, some concerned movie watchers
took issue with the use of the phrase "intergalactic
sociopath" to describe Thanos, the purple-faced
despot who committed mass genocide with the
snap of his Infinity Gauntlet-adorned fingers.
Some felt as though the label didn't completely
fit, given how subjective and ill-defined
some people consider the term "sociopath"
to be.
Thus, fans did what most everyone does nowadays
when they need to blow off steam and have
their thoughts heard: they headed to Twitter
to air their grievances in true Festivus fashion.
One wrote:
"Isn't Thanos a psychopath, not a sociopath?
Pls correct me if my dumbass is wrong."
Another had this to say:
"[...] does this mean that Thanos knows that
what he's doing is wrong, but is doing it
anyway because he's stubborn?
Does he truly believe that wiping half of
life from the universe is key to saving it?"
One Marvel fan was certain that Netflix royally
messed up in classifying Josh Brolin's Mad
Titan as a sociopath, tweeting, "Really take
issue with Netflix categorizing Thanos as
a sociopath.
He's clearly not."
Of course, until we get Thanos on the couch,
it's difficult to say with absolute certainty
whether the Mad Titan has a diagnosable personality
disorder at all.
To summarize the two disorders in a not-at-all
scientific way, the generally accepted difference
between psychopathy  and
sociopathy is that a psychopathic
individual will not feel empathy or have a
sense of morality.
Meanwhile, a sociopathic person, by contrast,
does have a sense of morality, having the
knowledge that a particular action is bad,
but going ahead and doing it anyway.
But despite these differences, the two terms
are frequently conflated.
And because none of us at home can truly know
whether Thanos felt bad about eradicating
half the universe's population or if he knew
that it was wrong but still did it anyway,
it's not hard to see why some fans have confused
the alien megalomaniac for being more of a
remorseless psychopath than regret-refusing
sociopath.
Want to see more of this debate?
Of course you do!
Back to the Tweets:
"He's a far more dangerous villain than a
sociopath — he's obsessed with his own power,
and believes what he's doing is right."
Another fan responded, tweeting:
"That's actually a psychopath.
Sociopaths can feel empathy and regret but
ignore it to achieve their goal.
Psychopathy is the absence of, or impaired,
empathy.
During the movie, Thanos did exhibit signs
of remorse.
Especially when it came to Gamora.
"A sociopath is what he is.
He cried.
He showed remorse.
People are confusing sociopathy with psychopathy.
Psychopathy is the ABSENCE of remorse or empathy."
As tired as you probably are of this discussion,
imagine how everyone else on the internet
felt.
The result of the exhausting back-and-forth
between the tweeting armchair psychiatrists
was that many outlets on the Internet started
reporting that Netflix had actually changed
the description of the movie to remove the
word "sociopath," instead describing Thanos
as "Invader.
Annihilator.
So-called savior."
Of course, as of the making of this video,
opening up Infinity War on Netflix reveals
the same sociopathic language as ever — at
least for some users.
It's unclear if these reports seem to indicate
that Netflix has slowly begun rolling out
a changed synopsis, or if some people are
just getting confused by the two descriptions
that Netflix includes on all of its movies.
Just like the debate between whether Thanos
is a psychopath and sociopath, this question
is likewise pointless and frustrating.
It is, indeed, a truly perfect note to close
out the year of 2018.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.